so I'm gonna start out with a super
exciting legal disclaimer this basically
says that I'm not trying to solicit any
of you guys to invest with two sigma and
I'm not giving out any investment advice
both of which should be very obvious as
I start talking so I'll start with a
little bit about me I'm standing here
definitely not terrified to be giving my
first-ever presentation at a conference
like this yay Hao and I practice it now
unconscious so for someone who shares a
name with a programming language I don't
have a ton of knowledge about computer
science probably I have the least
knowledge of computer science of anyone
in this room protip always start off
your talk by immediately undermining
your own authority so what I actually
have a bit of expertise in is music I
was a music major at Yale and then I
went to the NYU Tisch program in
graduate musical theater writing which
little-known fact you can get an MFA in
musical theater writing so it was this
lovely super supportive community which
I'm still really passionately involved
in but last year I got a chance to
become involved in a new community so
how did I get here I've been working at
2 Sigma investments which is an
investment company here in New York for
about 8 years and I started there as a
receptionist or if you're a fan of
anagrams which I am a telephone girl
repeating hello so I did that for a
couple of years and then I transferred
on to our Learning & Development team
but last year I transferred to a role
that was both new to me and new for the
company I became two Sigma's first
open-source coordinator so my musical
background was actually better
preparation for this than you might
imagine because in the musical theater
when you're writing a musical it's all
about having an idea that you care so
much about and almost immediately you
need to get other people on board so
since I'm a composer I needed to find a
playwright in the Louis's to provide the
words and then you need actors you need
a director you need designers and you
work really hard with all these people
to build up this huge thing
and then eventually you need to convince
audience members that they want to come
and see your thing so I think there's a
little bit of a parallel with open
source development in that you know
maybe instead of getting actors and
designers you're getting Co contributors
and instead of an audience you're
getting users but either way it's about
building a community or add something
you really care about so I had my
awesome musical background but I was
still missing a lot of domain-specific
knowledge so I gobbled up that great
karl fogel book producing open source
software and I basically just asked a
lot of questions and everyone was very
nice and would talk to me you guys are
lovely community who is nice about
answering questions when people have
them so when I first we been thinking
about 2 Sigma being involved in open
stories it was a little bit
counterintuitive to me because at 2
Sigma intellectual property is something
we think really hard about we've got
these really robust security systems
we've got redundant servers we think
really hard about what information is
where and of course we're not gonna go
out there and open source model code
that would be crazy
but even if we open source anything that
could be perceived as a competitive
advantage that we're giving away it's
doing a disservice to our investors so
that impact is felt by say the Texas
teachers pension fund to name a
particularly sympathetic example so this
is a graph from the Eclipse Foundation
of five stages of open source
involvements because while it's sort of
obvious why a finance company has to
think really hard about the risk forward
of getting involved in open source it's
something that any company has to really
wrestle with so way down at the bottom
left here is denying the existence of
open source that's pretty harsh I don't
think we were ever there but moving up
and they at diagonal we have using open
source contributing championing and then
they delineate this section this blue
part where your involvement with open
source is not coming from your engineers
but for the whole company the whole
company putting in resources and the
whole company getting value back so this
is things like recruiting and I think
it's worth noting that while on this
graph it looks sort of like a straight
line it's actually more like an
to a curve I think it's really difficult
to as a company to hop from one stage to
the next so 2 Sigma back in say 2012 I
think we were firmly in that first box
we did use open source and in fact the
company has some pretty strong ties to
the open source world one of our
founding members was an early
contributor to VSD which is cool but for
our first 11 years or so of existence
that was about the end of it it wasn't
until 2012 the bunch of engineers who
felt really passionately about it and a
bunch of people in our legal team all
got together to hash out how we could
safely be involved with open source so
we created an open source committee
which was charged with looking at
requests to contribute to open source
and deciding whether they were safe and
something we could approve
we made a formal approval process which
is a Vanita workflow for us and just
last year we formed a new intellectual
property steering committee to evaluate
those edge cases where we weren't really
sure if this was something that would
give away competitive advantage or not
and as we got all these things in place
we started open sourcing projects that
we developed in-house so I'll tell you
about a few of those later this first
one is an on-demand web service platform
that launches managers and other skills
services on missus missus being another
open source project about managing
computer clusters but not one made by us
so we love missus and we made a big bet
on it sticking around which is why we
built something on top of it so another
open source project arises cook we
developed cook to solve a problem we had
in-house which is that we've got over a
hundred users doing analysis that wants
a lot of computes that want more compute
than we have to offer so we made cook
which is a dynamic fair job scheduler to
figure out an efficient and fair way to
allocate the resources that we did have
and we've open source to get meta which
is about managing a bunch of
repositories is get sub modules and
we've open sourced halite which is an AI
game and competition which i believe is
still open it's a nice second season if
anyone wants to play and you can find
information about all of these projects
at 2 Sigma IO which I linked at the end
so looking at
so weird it's never happened before
there's bullets there too but they each
get their own side you'll see them so
before we talk about the reasons to
contribute I want to talk a little bit
about the risks so I mentioned the IP
risk there is also this risk of time
investment in addition to the time of
the people who are evaluating whether a
request to contribute is safe to go out
the legal team that's drawn up all these
documents and is making sure that we're
doing things station correctly
the marketing team is making us cool
logos a lot there's also the employees
themselves who are spending time doing
this work and all its people are
spending time doing this that they could
be doing other projects at T Sigma so
that's sort of a risk or an investment
there's also this idea of the burden of
support let's say that we open-source
something and it's lucky enough to find
users and find a home in the community
if we ever stopped using that project
internally we're in this weird position
where we're stuck either supporting
something that we no longer use or
visiting something which is just not
good behavior in the community we don't
want to do either of those things
reputationally there's also just the
risk of putting out anything less than
stellar software if we put something out
we want it to be code we stand behind
and we want it to be useful we also
don't want to just hoist unnecessary
programs out into the world which at
best is you know sort of neither here
nor there but at worst could be divisive
to the community there's also risks
associated with using open-source
software we have to think a lot about
licenses we don't want to bring anything
in the to GPL or a left copy because the
worst case scenario there is that
somehow that will touch model code but
then we're gonna be compelled to open
source model code which is not something
we want to do okay so looking at the
reasons the rewards the reasons why it's
good to contribute I think the most
obvious one is about leveraging other
people's work it's just it's universally
efficient to if something already exists
the solves our problem we have to use
that thing and try to make it better as
opposed to reinventing the wheel
ourselves this all conferred the
advantage of letting us benefit from
expertise out there in the world that we
might not
of within two sigma another great perk
is if we're contributing to a project we
have the chance to shape that projects
trajectory which is really cool when
you're contributing to open source
you're contributing to a common language
so we have a lot of proprietary systems
within two sigma so when we hire someone
we spend a lot of time upfront
teaching them to use these internal
programs that maybe they've never heard
of before and so this is time invested
upfront and it's time that's not
transferable if that employee ever does
want to go somewhere else but if you're
working with the community in the
open-source world you can immediately
communicate with and collaborate with
everyone else there's also this idea of
the Galapagos effect which you guys
probably already know about but I
thought it was interesting to learn
about the idea that if you were
developing within the walls of your
company on your little island it's
really easy to viewer far away from what
the rest of the world is doing which can
be inconvenient if you ever wanted to
sync up with the rest of the world later
it could also be easy to trick yourself
into thinking that because what you have
on your little island is the best thing
on that island that it's the best thing
in the world which may not be the case
okay so it's super important reasons to
do anything to be cool can't stress
enough how much I personally am very
interested in being cool two sigma is
not necessarily invested in Julia's
personal quest in this regard but two
sigma as a company wants to be cool too
by that I just mean we want to be a
place where the brightest most curious
most interesting engineers want to work
and we find that a lot of people that
we're really excited about working with
are really passionate about open source
so two Sigma's reason d'etre is about
solving hard problems we want to build
this legacy of being a company that has
tackled really hard problems and found
interesting solutions and we find that a
lot of the problems that we're really
interested in working on are so big that
we can't actually do it on our own so in
order to sort of level up our own legacy
that we're trying to build we need to
collaborate with the larger community
there's also this idea of a personal
legacy if you work in a finance company
you could work on a project that you're
really proud of but the number of people
who will see your work can be pretty
small but in the open source world you
can build a legacy virus
by putting out what you did so everyone
can see is and we do think that
basically contributing to open source
makes the world a better place whether
it's because we can solve these hard
problems that are too big for us to
solve alone
we're just ideologically speaking we
think it is the right thing to do so
it's good for the world and it is good
for us so switching from that sort of
rosy perspective let's take a look at a
dark doomsday scenario done done a day
without open stories so we use open
source a lot at T Sigma we use pandas
and Jupiter and numpy to do our analysis
to name just a few we use spark for
distributed computing we use git to
store our code and if these projects
were no longer being actively maintained
and developed there's a lot of stuff we
would no longer be able to do and we're
not the only ones in this position I
would redo that most companies in the
fortune 500 depend on some sort of open
source even if it's just Linux servers
which by the way are also powering our
PlayStation 3 Playstation 4 and intend
to switch all sorts of things so if this
infrastructure just disappeared
a lot of things would just grind to a
halt as one recent example Theano a
numerical computation library on Python
just announced that within a year work
is going to stop entirely on the project
so this was interesting news for other
projects like PI MC 3 and caris who are
designed around Theano and now have to
rethink what they're gonna do so I
couldn't say for sure whether if the a
knows shuttering has anything to do with
the lack of financial support but what I
do know is that they're using
development does have a widespread
effect and Theano isn't an isolated
example so there's been a that probably
the most important sentence in this talk
which is that the public digital
infrastructure is not free and it's not
invulnerable a lot of the projects that
are most widely used don't enjoy
widespread support looking at number for
example they receive their first grant
from the Moore Foundation just this past
summer
so these projects that we all depend on
they don't just appear for free they
need developer time and that needs money
and this challenge of making sure that
this ecosystem we all depend on is
healthy is a relatively new one but it
means now is the time when we all need
to sort of start thinking about our
responsibility to it so it reminds me a
little bit of the psychological
phenomenon of the bystander effect which
is this idea that if there's something
that needs to happen and a large number
of people who could do the thing but no
single person who's been singled out to
do it our natural response is to step
back and let someone else do it whether
that's because we're afraid to do it or
we think someone else could do it better
or we just don't want to do it and I
think this could apply to companies when
it comes to open source as well there
are a lot of companies that could make
real substantial contributions to the
open source ecosystem but I think at
this stage we're still evaluating
whether it's in our best interest to do
that or whether we sift it back and see
if someone else is going to so to
explain why I think it is in our own
best interest to stack up to step up and
support this community we will look at
the future so 2 Sigma does not predict
the future see aforementioned disclaimer
if I was even to begin to suggest that
we could I'd probably be violating a
whole bunch of SEC regulations we do not
but we are in the business of its
gathering as much information as we can
to try to make informed decisions about
what might happen so this could be on
the small scale looking at how a stock
price might change from day to day or it
could be on a larger scale thinking
about what the entire technical
ecosystem is going to look like 10 years
from now so if we build our tech stack
on an open source project we are making
an implicit forecast that we think that
thing is going to be around in the
future and the good news is we can
affect that future it's like that great
Allen case quote the best way to predict
the future is to invent it
so by contributing our time our energy
our financial support to the open source
eco structure ecosystem that we depend
on we're a future producing our own and
mence so how are we doing this when we
were doing this is by open sourcing
tools that we develop into Sigma
especially tools that we think that make
existing projects more useful for more
people another way is just by directly
contributing to projects that we use and
care about and finally we want to do
what we can to build community so I want
to go back to touch on two more tools
that we've generated into Sigma and open
source so Beeker started its life as a
polyglot notebook in 2013 and we were it
was our very first open source project
beaker is going along and at the same
time ipython notebook wit some became
Jupiter was going along and we saw that
Jupiter was just gaining huge popularity
both in the wider world and within two
sigma so last year we were thinking
about what to do about this and what we
decided was to pivot to make speaker the
notebook into beaker access added
extensions for Jupiter and my colleague
TZ is giving a whole talk on that
process tomorrow it's an awesome talk
you guys should check it out but so when
we decided we wanted to make the set of
extensions we knew that we didn't want a
fork Jupiter for all the reasons you
might not want to fork something we
didn't want to miss out on downstream
changes things like this so we had all
these conversations with core developers
on the project and we worked with them
to sort of get alive with their Road
backed and we did get our set of
extensions incorporated into the main
branch which is really exciting for us
because we got the features that we
really wanted in this project that we
loved and hopefully other people can
take advantage of those features in the
project - so Flint was another
interesting one for us because of this
intellectual property question so Flint
is about doing time series analysis on
SPARC and there is a lot of internal
discussion about this because time
series analysis is pretty close to our
core business but the thing that kind of
sealed the deal for us to open-source it
was that Flint is built on SPARC so we
use Sparkle add it to Sigma it's
something that we really want to stick
around and to thrive so we thought that
if Flint will extend sparks usefulness
to other people
it's full string spoke and therefore
that's a good reason for us to put it
out there another way we contribute to
the open source ecosystem is by directly
contributing to projects so we have a
couple open source rockstars at C Sigma
including West McKinney Jeffery vac Phil
cloud and their work on pandas on arrow
on Ibis are another way that T Sigma
gives back we're also trying to get
other people at the company involved in
open source contribution so we have a
weekly open source hack night where this
pizza and beer and we do an annual open
source hackathon which is a day-long
event focused on a single project so
last year we did that on Jupiter the
year before we did pandas and we've run
leading up to it
workshops about the open source
contribution workflow we give lectures
on what this project is and why it's
useful and cool to contribute to and we
work with the contributors of the
project we work with the core developers
on the project to curate a list of
issues that are tackle within a single
day and that may be someone who's never
contributed to open source before could
still dig into so we had about 30
participants last year we had a little
over 30 accepted pull requests and we're
hoping that those numbers go up this
year
so finally bolstering the community
there is some really easy ways to do
this we love opening our space up for
open source meetups things like this but
we also look to places like num focus to
help us figure out the best way to help
the community so num focus in case
anyone doesn't know in addition to being
a sponsor of this conference Thank You
number kissed is also a nonprofit that
supports scientific open source projects
for scientific computing so they do this
by giving funds to projects that need
funds but also by giving infrastructure
and support for financial things and
legal things that if you're a very small
project you might not be equipped to
deal with so two Sigma became a gold
sponsor of Nome focus this year and
we're really excited to be working with
them so I'm gonna finish up my talk by
returning to this graph so
- Sigma does use open-source does
contribute open-source I would argue
that we are championing open-source but
what my job I think is is to try to
figure out how to get us into this blue
parts and we are still figuring out how
to do this but I hope that as this
community continues to be so kind and
helpful I can chat with all of you and
chat with a bunch of people and
hopefully not only to Sigma but a whole
bunch of companies can be here in the
future giving talks about how happy they
are to be in that upper right hand
corner so thank you guys so much for
viewing so nice this was really fun not
too scary um if you want to check out to
Sigma open-source projects there's two
Sigma I oh I've got my email address up
there I've got my website which I'll
warn you is all music but I still think
it's cool and I've got my Twitter handle
it's probably been three years since
I've treated but I could always get back
on the wagon um if you guys have any
questions I'd be happy to take them now
otherwise have a lovely lunch thank you
[Applause]
yeah
yeah that's interesting I hadn't thought
about that before the question was would
we ever be provided just open
information on exactly how our IP
steering committee and our approval
process works if other people want to
use that model yeah I'd be curious what
the Bloomberg model is we're we're
pretty transparent within the company
and that there's full visibility into
whether request is approved or denied
and in either case why but yeah that
could be an interesting blog post or
something I don't think there's anything
secret about it any other questions
well thanks guys
[Applause]